first I'm interested to get your
reaction to the resignation of amber art
she mentioned the expulsion of the 21
and peace including yourself as part of
the reason for resigning not only from
tablet but also the concept of when well
I think for me the principal issue is
that she's been clear that there isn't
really a negotiation going on with the
EU to try and get any kind of brexit
deal and from my perspective I've been
waiting to see the Prime Minister get on
a plane to Brussels that's not happened
yet and so my concerns always been that
there isn't really a negotiation
happening on brexit now and therefore
the main objective of the government is
to leave with no deal and I think
certainly for my community that's been
completely unacceptable and that's why I
voted for this bill this week which
simply allows Parliament a binding vote
on any deal were borås to get one but
also a binding vote on no deal and
that's how we run Britain it's a
parliamentary democracy and I think it's
incredibly important to protect that so
I welcome that amber has even after we
had the vote chosen to support it at
same time you talked to you there about
trying to stop no deal you could have
done that by voting for a deal under to
resume
well it was clear to me that that deal
was never going to get through
Parliament I said back in the people
well I said in July last year actually
that it was obvious it didn't deliver on
the referendum as far as leavers was
concerned and for communities like mine
which are overwhelmingly remained people
just thought what's the point we're
following all the rules it's far smarter
to still be sat around the table setting
them so I think in reality it was clear
that was a brick wall the government
chose to run into it three times in
spite of it being obvious to me that it
wasn't a viable strategy okay and in
response to amber on to them resignation
you can have a quick look at something
your colleague David Gork tweeted at a
former conservative like yourself he
said and the rod has been
extraordinarily brave but her concerns
about how the government is behaving
reflect the views of many of my former
colleagues one way or another it's time
for them to act I mean do you agree with
David gorg is it time for more
conservative MPs to make their
unhappiness known I believe many will
this weekend be trying to work out the
right thing to do I think the reality is
for me it's impossible to stand by and
simply allow a government to inflict and
no deal brexit on Britain for me it is
the most profoundly unconservative
policy I have ever seen it destroys jobs
it harms our economy it damages
opportunity it will damage social
mobility and I find it hard to reconcile
that with the Conservative Party that's
for me always been about a vehicle for
social mobility and one of the reasons I
said I couldn't run as a Conservative
candidate on Tuesday this week was
because I think the Conservative Party
is now fixated on brexit brexit is its
priority above everything else and that
is simply not a priority for me when I
compare it to the chance to work on
social mobility and equality of
opportunity I think that's the real
issue facing Britain and when I look at
communities like the one I grew up in
Rotherham I would much rather be working
on the ground trying to practically make
a difference and I think the change that
people in those communities need is
actually access to opportunity I think
brexit takes them further away from the
solutions that I believe they deserve I
mean you mentioned there growing up in
bothering me you were the first
education secretary to be educated at a
comprehensive school which is a shocking
shocking indictment on Britain actually
that was the case if you if you were you
know that young girl in Rotherham would
you still be attracted to the
Conservative Party today
I think I'd see it as a party that was
about brexit not equality of opportunity
and what I've decided is we can't allow
this gridlock in Westminster to stop
change from happening on the ground in
communities that want it and that's what
I'm going to put my time into I mean
what some people would say is actually
brexit is the big dividing line of the
day Boris Johnson has a clear position
on brexit of course it's right that
people who don't support that position
should not be in the concept of
mati well I from my perspective
I had the wit was drawn this week but I
haven't really followed brexit for some
time so I felt it was somewhat of a
token gesture and also self-defeating
from the government but I do think that
the Conservative Party will not be
successful unless it is able to reach
out to a broad spectrum of the British
population and reach out to very
different communities including my own
in Putney and I think for it to
effectively turn its back on the views
of a community like my own is is frankly
totally unacceptable and I've always
been very clear my job is to represent
Putney in Parliament I am Putney's voice
in Parliament and I will fulfill that
role come what may
so with that in mind will you be voting
for an election well not if the election
is simply designed to enable the
government to dissolve Parliament and
time out tomorrow No Deal you're going
to be virtually against an election yes
because I think it's not an election
that is designed to do anything other
than take away choices from the British
people I believe if the British people
want to see a No Deal depart from the EU
they're the ones who should vote for it
it shouldn't be Boris Johnson just
simply timing out the clock
even though people's representatives in
Parliament are very clearly saying that
that is not something their communities
want we know that you're standing down
at the next election as Conservative MP
who are we going to be voting for well I
think like many people in my community I
will see what the candidates are saying
about how they want to represent us what
their views on issues are I have to say
the response from my local community has
been fantastic and the support I've had
over the past few days has been amazing
people of email me stopped me in the
street to say that they feel I'm doing
my job as an MP so you're not you're
you're not sure if you're going to vote
conservative or the next election then
you might vote for someone else I remain
a member I remain a member of the
Conservative Party but I think at the
end of the day I'm like every voter I
will try and work through what I feel
the right thing is for my
community in my country and then cast my
vote accordingly and I really would urge
the Conservative Party to consider how
it can make sure it can continue to
reach out to communities like my own and
I think we are we are owed a proper
choice in this election and I am worried
that Britain faces a lose-lose choice
either a No Deal Boris Johnson
government or a hard left Marxist
effectively Corbin government I don't
think that's the kind of choice that the
British people deserve I think they
deserve something much much better than
that and I hope that in the end Britain
will work its way through this broke
trick gridlock and then we have to at
some point get on to what I feel is the
big issue facing Britain which is
inequality of opportunity and all I can
say is that I don't plan to leave
frontline politics I plan to put my time
into fixing what I think the real
challenge is for Britain which is an
equality of opportunity and that
whenever Britain is able to get onto
that real debate I will be at the front
of that debate leading the charge and
hopefully making a difference on the
ground in the meantime I'm it just
finally I'm came to know what happened
when the news was broken that you'd be
stripped to the conservative whip I mean
who spanked you how do they get in touch
well I was travelling home on the
district line I don't normally do and I
had a call from the chief where privacy
wasn't able to take it on the tube so he
simply left a voicemail and what did I
say just informed me that the wit was
being withdrawn I think it might have
been polite after 14 years to try to
call me back perhaps a second time but
the bottom line Sofie is that I think we
are where we are and I I'm very clear
what my role is and my role is to
represent my community in Parliament and
that's what I did that day so did you
have any conversations after that
because Boris Johnson tried to get in
touch with you and they Dominic Cummings
nobody else has called you about to
called you about call
no just the voicemail just a voicemail
and how does that make you feel what
look I think it says an awful lot more
about I guess the state is a
Conservative Party
and it does about me and and I think in
a way I have served my community in my
country for 14 years and I think it's a
shame that the whip has been withdrawn
for me doing the simple thing of
representing my community in Parliament
I'm not in control of how the
conservative leadership takes its
decisions I think it was a
self-defeating move to withdraw the whip
and I think it will backfire but
ultimately those are questions for
Dominic Cummings and Boris Johnson more
than they are for me